At the conference, I was at with Meg useful. It was said not to use iron skillets as iron is
not good for cancer. I have been taking spirulina and florella which has
much iron and it constipates me. I learned these are great for breast cancer but is the iron
produced not worth the health benefits. I could be wrong but I don't think there's a lot of iron
and florella and spirulina. But certainly iron can be constipating especially if it's
if it's ferrous sulfate which is a lot of the iron of the market which is just elemental iron
which is bad. I don't know how much iron is in those things. I don't think there's a lot of iron in
that. You know, iron that's in food like in different foods. That's a food-based iron that's
totally different. If you're taking exogenous iron because you have low hemoglobin, low red blood cells,
if you have an amemia, you want to if your take have to take iron exogenously for your amemia,
you want to take an iron bisglycinate, a good quality iron that is
similar to a plant-based iron, double bonded to an amino acid. I always suggest taking
artimisticid with the iron because if your cancer cells are gobbling out iron, you want them to
gobble up the artimisticid, the artimisticid travels with iron so it'll then cause the cancer cell
to gobble up the artimisticid that could help kill the cancer cell. So if you have to take iron
because of an amemia then I would do that. If you don't have an amemia but you're getting iron
in just food, then I wouldn't be concerned about that. We could certainly take artimisticid. If you
think that the chlorella and spirulina has too much iron, you could take its artimisticid with it.
But I am not an advocate to use iron skillets as a way to get iron. Now, understand, I don't think
that if you're using a cast iron skillet, you're getting a lot of iron from that skillet
as long as they don't think you are. If your iron skillet has been properly
prepared, meaning that it's got a coating on it of fat, which your iron skillet should have
if you read it correctly. So you're not getting a lot of iron from iron skillets, but some people
have done that and that can be a issue. I always use a carrier oil, I think you're referring to
the frankincense. Yeah, then I don't have a perfect answer for you. I don't know if that's a good
paid or bad paid maybe just lay off a bit for a little bit. Maybe it has nothing to do with frankincense.
Maybe try eliminating it for a period of time.